mesdames et messieurs bonsoir dans la
crise iran etats unis c'est l'impasse
totale adhérents monsieur banny sabres
responsable des affaires étrangères a
exclu à nouveau toute possibilité de
compromis en vue de la libération des
otages
alors qu'aux états unis les chefs
d'états majors des trois armées ont tenu
une réunion conjointe
je rappelle qu'hier soir le président
carter avait déclaré à l'adresse de la
traque est finie
si vous touchez un seul des otages
encore retenus ce lara les conséquences
d'une extrême gravité
cette mise en garde a eu un grand
retentissement dans le monde entier mais
jusqu'à quel point at elle impressionné
les iraniens on peut se le demander car
ferrand vie dans une atmosphère
d'exaltation extrême et pour mieux
comprendre ce climat je vous invite à
suivre le reportage de notre envoyé
spécial
philippe roche l'iran vient d'entrer
dans le mois de moharram le mois du
martyr de la pénitence et du deuil c'est
le mois le plus important chez les
musulmans chiites puisque leur histoire
s'est joué dans cette période où les
califes omeyyades ont tué leurs
disciples à la bataille de kerbala
depuis ce temps ils sont les martyrs de
l'histoire c'est en martyr du shah
d'iran qui défilaient dans les rues l'an
passé c'est en martyr de l'amérique
qu'il organise ces processions cette
année mais aujourd'hui l'armée est à
leurs côtés les otages servent de boucs
émissaires on appelle la foule autour de
l'ambassade des états unis on déguise un
homme en marine et l'on crie sa haine à
carter et à l'amérique
ici on s'arrache littéralement des
lambeaux de drapeaux américains pour les
brûlures l'iran de l'ayatollah khomeiny
à trouver les responsables de ses
malheurs
cet homme dit qu'il veut un procès
public pour les espions américains parce
que nos rapports avec l'amérique ne
correspondent pas à nos aspirations
nous ne sommes pas contents de nos
relations avec les états unis
nous voulons les rendre nous voulons
être indépendant ces dix otages libérés
lundi auront bénéficié de la clémence de
l'ayatollah khomeini mais leurs
camarades enfermés dans des chambres
séparées ou déjà dispersés dans des
prisons de la ville vont commencer à
vivre un interminable procès celui de la
politique américaine
car dans ce tribunal c'est tous ses
rapports avec les états unis que l'iran
entend juger et même ceux qui défendent
les droits de l'homme en iran justifie
ce procès car les américains ont violé
ses droits les premiers en accueillant
un criminel le chat lorsque le
gouvernement américain à lui donner un
visage enduit de l'indrois 2d d'asile on
a violé l'article 14 de carrasso doit de
l'eau lorsque un gouvernement a violé un
principe droits de l'homme on ne parlera
attendre leur respect d'autres princes
et de droits de l'homme ou d'autres
principes internationaux parce que c'est
le gouvernement américain qui a fini et
qui à renoncer
la protection internationale et la
protection des principes droits de
l'homme dans ce cas on doit attendre
leur action arbitraire
voici ceux qui seront les procureurs les
juges et les avocats des otages
américains
ce sont les étudiants islamiques
eux-mêmes conduit par le gâteau les
slams rohini chaque matin dans
l'ambassade devenue prison et lieu de
pèlerinage
ils font en bon musulman la prière de
midi
c'est là que devra se tenir le tribunal
en public afin dit on que les iraniens
assiste au procès de l'amérique à
travers ces espions
quelle forme de justice vont ils leurs
réserves et l'islam considère
l'espionnage comme une forme de crime
mais la question reste aujourd'hui
jusqu'où les états unis laisseront-ils
l'iran allait trop loin dans son procès
de l'amérique et bien l'amérique dans
tout cas répond ce qui la concerne les
côtes américaines puis 100pts fait route
vers le golfe persique et son approche
maintenant après vite groupés autour de
deux porte-avions lagence soviétique
tass selon elle des éléments héliportée
de l'aéronautique américaine serait déjà
en place à dharamsala bisséous dit c'est
à dire à moins de 250 km des côtes
iraniennes
mais les hommes seraient en civil et
passerait pour des techniciens de la
compagnie pétrolière américaine aramco
affirmation non confirmée pour l'instant
et je viens de vous la donner d'ailleurs
conditionnelle en tout cas moscou a
rappelé derechef au respect des
conventions diplomatiques
internationales et le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères monsieur gromyko a
lancé aux deux parties en présence
un appel à la retenue il n'a pas donné
l'impression au contraire de vouloir
mettre de l'huile sur le feu que va
décider monsieur carter de washington
notre correspondant permanent
jacques singh mais aux dernières
nouvelles et pour la deuxième fois en 48
heures mais elle est venue de lens ou
musulmans du monde entier
une sorte d'appel à la guerre sainte
profondément anti amis alors la solution
à apporter à ces difficultés là la
solution aux divers conflits qui explose
un peu partout dans le monde
est ce la guerre c'est là une
interrogation fondamentale qui surgit
dans l'esprit d'un nombre de plus en
plus élevées de nos contemporains ne
sera posée lundi
à 20h35 à l'émission question qu'un
grave des bars perspective avec en
direct des invités tels que michel
poniatowski edgard pisani
tous deux anciens ministres pour les
interroger louis berio et georges
bortoli et nous vous y présenteront
également des reportages tournés par le
correspondant à l'étranger
lundi donc à 20h35 cette interrogation
angoissante fondamentale la solution la
guerre il ya 50 ans aujourd'hui que
georges clemenceau le père la victoire
de 14 18
c'était un pari et 88 ans dix ans après
la signature du traité de versailles
pour célébrer l'anniversaire de sa mort
le ministre de la défense monsieur yvon
bourges a fleuri ça tombe à mouchamps a
bandé sous un cèdre centenaire et dans
l'enclos du côlon cinq ans après le vote
de la loi sur l'interruption volontaire
dé grossesse
les députés auront à se prononcer lundi
et mardi sur un texte du gouvernement
proposant la reconduction de la loi veil
le projet s'il est adopté donnera un
caractère permanent à la loi de janvier
75 appliqué jusqu'ici vous savez à titre
transitoire au parlement le débat sera
aussi passionné sans doute qu'à l'époque
et sur le fond des arguments échangés ne
devrait pas être très différent
l'église elle n'a jamais varié
l'interruption volontaire dé grossesse
demeure pour elle un acte de mort seul
sans doute à ne pas camper sur ses
positions antérieures
l'ordre des médecins qui montrent une
plus grande ouverture il ya cinq ans
monsieur giscard d'estaing dans une
interview aujourd'hui à notre confrère
la croix rappelle les récentes mesures
prises en faveur de la famille il rend
publique par ailleurs une autre décision
qui est à l'étude à savoir
l'établissement d'un avantage fiscal
permanent pour les foyers ayant élevé au
moins trois enfants
puis le chef de l'état parle dans cette
interview également de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
le président prend clairement position
pour le maintien de la loi veil
il ne s'agit pas dit-il de choisir entre
la vie et la mort mais de faire face à
d' authentiques situation de détresse
quant aux patients elles sont toujours
aussi vives
le 6 octobre on a vu la marche des
femmes à paris organisée par divers
mouvements féministes puis à titre de
réponse d'une manifestation qu'on
l'avortement le 17 novembre et cet après
midi à paris très grande marche en
faveur de l'avortement
ils étaient plusieurs milliers cet après
midi à défiler de la bastille à
l'assemblée nationale pour manifester en
faveur de l'avortement libre et gratuit
90 personnes selon les organisateurs
kazmi en vous abonnant chiffres
provisoires
selon la préfecture de police et pour la
première fois dans l'histoire des
défilés pour l'avortement
les hommes sont présents hommes et
femmes sont réunis au coude à coude dans
un même combat
scandant les mêmes slogans ce n'est ni
au gouvernement ni à l'assemblée mais
aux femmes de décider
vingt-deux associations des sections
syndicales plusieurs partis de gauche
ont répondu à l'appel des collectifs
unitaires avortement contraception
quelques incidents vous de rivoli des
autonomes sont interpellés par la
commission mais vers 18 heures les
manifestants se dispersent dans le calme
sans accrochage avec le service d'ordre
au palais de justice de paris se tient
depuis hier le congrès du syndicat de la
magistrature l'un des deux organismes
auxquels peuvent adhérer les magistrats
l'autre étant l'union syndicale des
magistrats thème des travaux les juges
les démocraties votre compte rendu que
nous appelons le léon le syndicat de la
magistrature rassemble environ un petit
quart des 5000 magistrats français et
n'a jamais dissimulé dissimuler ses
courants de pensée de gauche
alors c'est une évidence que de dire non
seulement qu'il dérange les conceptions
de certains milieux politiques ce n'est
pas très grave mais également qu'il
trouble parfois l'image traditionnelle
du magistrat dans l'esprit de l'opinion
publique une image caractérisé dessinée
sera vidée au congrès par trois mots
c'était une boutade d'ailleurs sérieux
respectabilité silence ils troublent le
syndicat et c'est vrai il choque sans
doute plus par ces formules que par ses
intentions n'empêche qui n'est pas sans
intérêt de réfléchir sur deux problèmes
soulevés entre autres par ces jeunes
magistrats de problèmes dans les
solutions qu'elle quelle soit vont
définir la justice de demain premier
problème le poids de la raison d'état
sur les libertés individuelles ce n'est
pas la première fois que nous en parlons
ici et il n'est pas sûr d'ailleurs que
les français y prête une grande
attention jusqu'au bout - d'ailleurs où
ils sont directement concernés
la sécurité où l'intérêt général de la
société doivent-ils amputer le respect
même parfois douloureux et vous
douloureux parlons des droits personnels
de chaque individu et en exemple
syndicat de la magistrature site les
manifestations du 23 mars à paris les
policiers en civil la procédure de
flagrant délit
additionné à la loi anti-casseurs les
témoignages un certain provenant d'une
seule source et le risque finalement
pour un manifestant d'être
automatiquement soupçonné de violence et
de provocation
deuxième problème le rôle de la justice
face aux séquelles d'une économie en
situation de crise
on demande aux magistrats dit le
syndicat de la magistrature de juger en
fonction d'un système judiciaire anciens
formés sur vont des sur le critère du
travail de l'emploi
or dans un pays où il ya plus d'un
million de chômeurs comment décidez de
saisie arrêt sur le salaire de paiement
forcé d'expulsion ou des peines de
prison sans trahir la justice et la foi
que les citoyens ont en la justice fin
de citation
alors il faut pas se tromper un grand
nombre de magistrats syndiqués ou non se
pose ces questions tout en sachant
parfaitement que la réponse ne peut
venir que du monde politique et de ses
équilibres
en attendant les juges sont obligés
chaque jour de chercher la justice
et c'est peut-être cette recherche
parfois dramatiques explique les
questions et surtout les violences
verbales du 12e congrès du syndicat de
la magistrature 1600 délégués de la cftc
sans réunis à strasbourg pour le 40e
congrès de leur syndicat les dirigeants
de la cftc en affichant comme l'on dit
258 l'aveyron affirme ne pas être touché
par la crise renouvellement qui
préoccupe aujourd'hui d'autres syndicats
il déclaré au contraire progressé de 3%
par le thème essentiel des travaux de
strasbourg c'est la manière dont les
syndicalistes peuvent faire face à la
situation économique et sociale actuelle
une analyse de laurence graff depuis des
années on a eu une autre action
syndicale dans le cadre d'une expansion
importante cette expansion est cassé
aujourd'hui et ça pose vraiment toute
une série de défis à l'action syndicale
en ce qui concerne l'emploi et le
chômage
la politique contractuelle également
puisque la croissance est en grande
partie tari la sauvegarder et peut-être
même la survie de l'eau régime de
protection sociale qui sont si
importants pour les travailleurs las de
ces défis qu'est ce que vous proposez
nous disons qu'il ya un certain nombre
de réponses techniques que le congrès
devra bien sûr précisé
mais il ya également toute une attitude
syndicale il faut arriver à recréer les
conditions d'un véritable dialogue
social dans ce pays et ça veut dire que
les employeurs comme les pouvoirs
publics doivent se mettre à table
effectivement est prendre les salariés
et les syndicats comme des
interlocuteurs véritable ça veut dire
aussi que les salariés eux mêmes doivent
s'en occuper davantage car on sait et
c'est grave
quelle majorité de salariés non
syndiqués dans ce pays et il faut
également que le syndicalisme lui-même
inspire confiance à ses salariés en
présentant vraiment un syndicaliste qui
méritent leur confiance l'histoire du
sport a connu de très grands champions
professionnels gagnant énormément
d'argent certaines vedettes de la boxe
certains d'odette du golfe atteignait ou
atteignent peut être encore des sommes
très élevées mais le recordman du monde
toutes catégories semble bien être le
numéro 1 actuel du tennis mondial le
suédois björn borg
on dit que le contrat qu'il a signé en
belgique lui rapportera chaque année
pendant cinq ans deux millions six cent
mille francs actuels au total sur cinq
années
13 millions actuels c'est à dire un
milliard trois cents millions anciens et
ce pour se servir d'une raquette bien
précise gérard holtz et hervé duthu ont
suivi le champion n'ont pas hélas pour
toucher avec les échecs mais pour
l'accompagner à travers quelques matchs
jusqu'à la signature de son contrat
une petite signature au bas d'un contrat
est une grosse somme d'argent en plus
sur le compte en banque de björn borg
déjà bien remplie une sorte de contrat
record pour que le champion suédois
jouent pendant cinq ans avec ses
raquettes la firme belge donnait lui
offre dit-on près d'un milliard et demi
de centimes
björn borg ne se contente pas d'être le
meilleur joueur du monde depuis trois
ans est aussi un homme d'affaires avisé
rien au hasard et cela même si son
emploi du temps
la semaine dernière la transformer en
chasseur de primes il a joué à innsbruck
lundi lyon mardi
toulouse jeudi bruxelles vendredi pour
des tournois exhibitions le tennis est
souvent loin d'être digne des champions
qui participent
hervé duthu lui a d'ailleurs demandé de
s'expliquer à ce sujet
christine antoine tournonnais meilleur
tennisman mondiaux joue entre 15 et 20
sournois pas je fais des exhibitions
pendant quatre semaines il sent que
pensez-vous de yannick tort en tant que
joueur et le voyez vous dans les
meilleurs très bientôt
en plus cette année particulièrement il
a très bien joué il a d'ailleurs gagné
quelques tournois beaucoup de
possibilités pour devenir un grand
joueur je pense que l'année prochaine il
sera bien dans la grande tour et mon
nexus est ce qu'on est devenu le
houellebecq tout en nommant bjorn borg
tout a été dit sur le joueur de tennis
que vous êtes mais en dehors du coup
vous restez toujours très secret je
pense qu'il est important de partager
une vitrine
c'est pourquoi je préfère ne pas en
parler d'ailleurs c'est l'autre garde
tous affublés d'une autre spectacle
commence
c'est un garçon normal dit sa fiancée
marianne simoni sport
surtout un tennisman exceptionnel sa
plus grande qualité c'est sa
concentration en filets sur un court
moi même je ne comprends même pas à quoi
il pense c'est un mystère
la concentration était tellement fort
tellement elles sont énormes
quoi qu en dise moi je joue au tennis je
connais le tennis donc on en parle
souvent quand il gagne un match nous on
parle on perd on n'en parle jamais
marianne simonis coup deviendra madame
borg le 24 juillet prochain c'est à dire
juste après le tournoi de wimbledon que
le numéro 1 mondiale espère bien gagner
pour la cinquième fois consécutive entre
deux exhibitions et avant d'aller jouer
le fameux master 2 janvier à new york
john borg a donc fait un détour par la
belgique hier pour visiter l'usiné de
flins qui sont fabriqués les 300
raquette du tibet en une année
lusine travail 520 personnes et où sont
fabriqués près de 8000 raquette par jour
un petit salut aux spécialistes qui
seront effectifs travaillent une poignée
de main et puis bornes board a quitté la
route à quitter l'usiné plutôt sûr ils
gagnent beaucoup d'argent m'a dit un
employé mais c'est quand même le premier
ouvrier lusine demain à auteuil la
réunion commence à 13 heures car elle
doit se terminer avant la chute du jour
sinon les chevaux ne verrez plus les
obstacles le tiers se dispute sur un
parcours d'une exceptionnelle difficulté
un style une chaise de 5500 mètres qui
portait jusqu'ici le nom de prix
montgomery et qui sera cette année le
grand prix de notre bon confrères paris
turf
les terrains étaient lourds ces jours
derniers mais la plus altérée avec des
périodes de froid qui sait les pistes
firme bresse vous donne ses pronostics
mais un nouveau changement de perrin
influerait beaucoup sur la manière dont
la course je suis traîné le temps s'est
adouci et demain au teil les pistes
seront seulement collante
le spectacle de ce tiercé sera sûrement
très passionnant et très beau car la
course s'adresse aux meilleurs chevaux
de steeple d'auteuil
la distance à parcourir sera longue bien
sûr ils devront sauter des plus gros
obstacles dont deux fois la rivière des
tribunes tout de suite je vous présente
temps l'as l'un des favoris de la course
le voici
c'est un des meilleurs chevaux de ce
type à auteuil ce sera un des meilleurs
et ça doit être le meilleur cinq ans
parce qu'il a de cinq ans est lui c'est
un tout il aura 69 kilos et demi
dimanche
oui est-ce qu'ils portent bien de
pouvoir très bien d'ailleurs il
accueille déjà veille que 69 et demi
contre les gueux show en le rendant du
poids à tous alors dans quelle somme est
il actuellement l'abbaye reviennet il
est parent père plein plein boom en fait
il est bien et je le bois dans les trois
premiers la course sera dure et je ne
serais pas étonné que les favoris soient
battus par un outsider
aussi je prends le risque de placer deux
seraient en tête de ma sélection
c'est une course qu'elle a déjà gagné en
1975 et sur sa forme du moment
elle a encore son mot à dire ensuite
saint brice temps que tout le monde
considère comme un phénomène
et puis temps là ce qui est une valeur
sûre dans cette spécialité
bettina est tombé lors de sa dernière
course mais cela n'enlève rien à ses
qualités
elle peut discuter la river le clou
laurent avait terminé troisième de
saint-brice temps malgré cela il n'est
pas trop pénalisés puisqu'ils ne porte
que 63 kg flight 2 est un demi cent tout
à fait digne de participer à cette
grande course
excellent sauteur il n'est jamais
ridicule quand ils affrontent les pur
sang
mais sierre et la fille de hyères iii
qui gagne à trois fois le grand
steeple-chase
et pour finir et quotas et qui vient de
faire une très bonne course de rentrée
c'est un cheval à suivre ils porteront
les numéros suivants 14 1 2 7-12 4 8 et
12 ballons ronds l'accueil de ceux à qui
que l'on avait joué l'autre jour pendant
la france a battu aujourd'hui luxembourg
et elles se qualifient donc pour la
phase finale de la coupe d'europe des
nations ballon ovale depuis 42 ans des
rugbymen anglais essaye de battre les
néo zélandais les tout noir les all
blacks comme on les appelle
mais sans y parvenir et cet après midi à
twickenham la tradition a été respectée
les néo-zélandais ont gagné 7 nombre
d'avoirs d'ailleurs avoir eu ce match en
direct je pense mais les anglais se sont
battus comme de beaux diables et non
succomber que d'un seul petit point
cergy soit
premier match international de l'équipe
d'angleterre et premières images de
l'édition 1979 1980 d'un essai le seul
hélas que les anglais soient capables de
réussir son titre faisant simple nous
proposons de la condition absurde du
joueur de rugby anglais
quoi de plus absurde en effet rugby que
de conquérir constamment le ballon et de
ne jamais parvenir à marquer des essais
les raisons de ce triste paradoxe la
faiblesse chronique des trois-quarts
anglais une faiblesse technique mauvaise
circulation de balle mais aussi tactique
cosworth bande l'attaquent meur au 1er
trois gars sortent enfin le très
impressionnant manque d'inspiration du
demi d'ouverture anglais c'était le 17e
demi d'ouverture essayé par les anglais
depuis six ans il s'appelle cause bois
le voilà en action
il attend la balle et il attendra
certainement longtemps sa deuxième
sélection
alors bien sûr dans ces conditions le
sauver c'est ne pouvait être remarqué
que par les all blacks plémy sur un
coupet a suite de l'offre élite
score final nouvelle zélande 10
angleterre 9 rugby d'attac 0
saviez vous que la poupée française
était considéré par les collectionneurs
du monde entier comme la plus belle du
monde des musées poupée française existe
ainsi à londres et edimbourg à nuremberg
est l'un des plus beaux musées est au
japon une bouffée de l'érection du 19e
siècle vous entre 1500 et 40 mille
francs figurez-vous récemment une poupée
dans la fleur de l'âge
elle avait 97 ans a été adjugé à plus de
60 mille francs or en france
s'il ya cent mille collectionneurs il
n'y a pas de véritable musée pourtant
depuis un mois des amoureux des petites
filles de porcelaine peuvent aller au
jardin d'acclimatation au bois de
boulogne à paris
et là dans une maison construite à
l'échelle d'enfants de 6 à 7 ans vivent
23 petites filles modèles ce sont les
images le jean louis doucet
un univers de rêve la reconstitution
d'une maison watts et satinée au début
de notre siècle
bon
on
ce petit fils n'ont pas grandi entre 60
et 80 cm pourtant la benjamine va sur
ses 55 ans l'aîné à plus de 100 ans
leurs objets usuels date de la même
époque
comme il serait bon de ne jamais sortir
du monde de l'enfance
m
il
ans
un court instant c'est bon de rêver
m
s'il m'a plus impressionné c'est leurs
yeux le temps dimanche lumière sur les
régions méditerranéennes éclaircies avec
nuage passager sur le massif central les
alpes le jura
la matinée sera très brumeuse avec de la
neige à basse altitude et de petites
pluies verglaçantes est clair si la can
l'après midi ailleurs le temps sera très
brumeux avec de nombreux brouillards
matinaux parfois givrants dans le centre
et le sud ouest en soirée petite pluie
sur les côtes de bretagne la 1re édition
est terminée les avaient rendez-vous
vers 23h30 avec berlin il vous donnera
les dernières informations de journée et
demain si tel est votre choix
nous avons deux rendez-vous à 12h45 pour
l'antenne de midi et le soir
ici même à 20 heures bonsoir merci à